en 2017 emmanuel macron nous avait
promis l'avènement d'un nouveau monde
cinq ans plus tard le quotidien des
français n'a pas changé leur vie s'est
pas améliorée au fond je crois qu
emmanuel macron était le président du
grand des plaques du grand déclassement
de notre pays aujourd'hui on a une
candidature qui est celle de valérie
pécresse qui est en mesure de battre
emmanuel macron est la seule qui est
capable de le battre on le voit dans
toutes les intentions de vote je crois
qu'elle a le courage je crois qu'elle a
la force je crois qu'elle a le dynamisme
et la fermeté pour redresser notre pays
son projet il est clair c'est un projet
de fermeté redresser notre pays à partir
de trois valeurs d'abord l'autorité de
l'état parce qu'il faut restaurer la
sécurité de tous les français ensuite la
liberté parce qu'il faut encourager de
génie français et puis la dignité pour
qu'on retrouve ensemble une france
apaisée et qu'on retrouve la fierté et
bonheur d'être français et je crois
qu'on assiste aujourd'hui à une faillite
de l'école les classements le monde
chaque année le classement steam ça a
montré qu'on avait les élèves en france
les plus mauvais d'europe en
mathématiques le classement pisa ne
montre qu'on perd des places chaque
année il faut six générations pour un
enfant des classes populaires pour
devenir pour accéder à la classe moyenne
ça c'est la réalité d'un ascenseur
social qui est bloqué dans une pays et
ça c'est la vraie question qu'il faut se
poser l'école elle est en faillite et
donc il faut la réparer nous ce qu'on
veut aujourd'hui c'est une école de
l'excellence et une école républicaine
qui prône l'assimilation c'est une école
dans laquelle on arrive à mettre en
place cette égalité des chances et pour
ça il faut rétablir par exemple les
bourses au mérite qui avaient été mises
en place comme hymne et quand valérie
pécresse enfin la mesure son ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur elles ont été
supprimés sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande elles ont été
maintenues dans la région ile de france
parce que valérie pécresse est là et la
prison de la région ile de france il
faut les généraliser dans tout le pays
parce qu'il faut valoriser si un accusé
un homme droit et sur la lutte sauvage
des étudiants qui ont eu la mention très
bien au bac et qui n'ont pas les moyens
pour aller étudier à l'université